um talk about uh
obviously Stunna is the I feel like I
mean I think I saw a comparison of like
a Stevie Wonder art and like your your
[ __ ] side by side but the artwork is so
fire because it just reminds me of
something like I would want to buy on
vinyl and hold yeah like yeah that was
that was really the um
the like the inspo is that was that
Stevie Wonder like we wanted to have
something like reminiscent of like a
vinyl like 70s funky yeah just I was
like damn I want to hold this [ __ ] yeah
yeah like that that's really what was
the like the real
um like inspo behind it we want to do
something like funky vibrant and that's
what and that's what like I think what
the music also like represents it's like
it's it's the music is vibrant it's
colorful and
um it's just like that it it sounds like
it sounds like it sounds like the cover
looks yeah it's and and the title feels
like an album called stunner yeah you
know what I'm saying you know I just
trying to put it all together trying to
think one plus one equal two 100 man no
it's great great artwork
um orange vinyls maybe or yeah come on
all right I'll let the powers that be
they're gonna be vinyls coming yeah yeah
oh limited edition no fizzy piece yeah
yeah come on limited edition that's not
that that's what that's in route